From my blood
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song Ice and Fire
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
video All About Valyrian steel swords the other
items during House of the dragon that currently
exist and belong to people at this point in the
timeline there are many more that we know about
later in the timeline during the visit of the
Game of Thrones series that eventually get lost
or stolen during Wars or other major events but
at this point in the timeline there are more in
existence that we know of and we know where they
are than in any other point in history some of the
valyrian steel weapons that we've been seeing on
the show actually do return during the events
of the Game of Thrones episodes so I'll explain
those Easter eggs too if you're brand new to the
channel I'm doing videos for all the episodes like
I did for the Game of Thrones series be sure
to subscribe to get them all we're also doing
a giveaway for HBO Max subscriptions all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me know
in the comments what your favorite Valyrian steel
weapon is not all of them are weapons though some
of them are just regular items some of them
are armor and some of them are crowns so I'll
explain those in a second too but Valyrian
steel is meant to be like a song of ice and
Fire's version of Damascus steel like an upgraded
version of Damascus steel and real life it weighs
far less and it's much stronger than normal steel
and they can use it to kill White Walkers whites
and the night King probably because it contains
dragonglass when people make new Valyrian steel
but the reason on House of the dragon and even
more so later during Game of Thrones that is so
rare and valuable so expensive is that the art of
making it is thought to have been lost with the
Doom of valyria so no one knows how to make new
Valyrian steel in the art of reshaping existing
Valyrian steel into other weapons or items
is also incredibly rare really good example
of that is Tywin Lannister having the Stark's
Greatsword ice melted down and reforest into
widow's whale and oath keeper the art of merely
reshaping it which itself is incredibly hard to
do is super rare like you can count the number
of people who can do it on one hand as the name
implies it was created by valyrians during their
rise to power while they were also in the process
of taming dragons and their blood mages were
developing the art of dragon bonding we don't
know if they created valyrian steel first or
if they tame dragons first the art of taming
dragons is something that took them a long time
it didn't happen overnight it was sort of like
the domestication of horses with a whole bunch of
blood magic involved I've already done a separate
video talking about that so I'll link it in the
description below and I'll talk more about the
dragons that we'll see in the future of the series
there'll be 17 total dragons during House of the
Dragon but we won't meet all of them during the
events of season one but really good example with
Valyrian steel so Daemon Targaryen wields dark
sister the ancestral blade of House Targaryen
that belonged to vicenia Targaryen aegon's sister
wife before him if you put a weapon like that that
weighs less in his way stronger in the hands of
someone who's a great fighter like Daemon it turns
them into a one-man wrecking crew just ripping
through most normal soldiers which is why he can
make a run like that even though he doesn't care
whether he lives or dies it's one of the reasons
why he can do stuff like that valyrian steel
is also resistant to most types of fire all but
dragon fire really good example of that the most
notable Valyrian weapon in the episode so far is
the catspaws' valyrian dagger wielded currently
by viserys he puts it in this fire to heat up
the blade revealing the Valyrian steel glyphs
etched into the blade by aegon the Conqueror who
had it made revealing his prophecy of A Song of
Ice and Fire the prophecy of the prince who was
promised if he did that with a normal blade
it would just ruin the blade also the other
cool detail here the new addition to the lore Big
reveal in the history of the cat's paws dagger is
that the dagger originally belonged to aegon the
Conqueror now because he wasn't born till after
the targaryens moved to Dragonstone it's possible
that he just got the dagger from another Target
like he was given the dagger as a present and
then he had the special message reforged into
it by Valyrian steel Smiths the way the books talk
about the history all art of making new valyrian
steel was lost during the Doom just because it
was such a big secret not that many people even
inside the valyrian freehold knew how to make it
and when the Doom happened all those people were
killed like it wasn't like they were going to
teach the art of creating new Valyrian steel to
any Smith that walked along it'd be like passing
out dragon eggs to anybody that just came through
your city here's a nuclear weapon just feel free
to use this however you want later especially if
our two-day Nations get into a fight so it wasn't
like the valyrians passed this knowledge on to
anybody that wanted to learn it so I do kind of
think that the dagger came from ancient valyria
and they just brought it with them when they
moved to Dragonstone and eventually it wound
up in the hands of aegon Tarkan and then when
he had the prophecy he had the prophecy itself
etched into the blade reforging it a little bit
and just for reference aegon the Conqueror even
though they treat him like this really ancient
Targaryen was actually Seventh Generation
Dragonstone so they'd already been there for a
long time before he decided to conquer Westeros
so aegon never saw valyria before the Doom unlike
valyrian the black dread balerian the black red
and Melisandre are like the two only living people
who survived close to the events of House of the
Dragon Melisandre is obviously alive that might
have had a chance of seeing valyria before the
Doom but the idea during ancient Valeria is
that the dragonlords have thousands of dragons
they each probably have their own weaponsmith
who's capable of creating new Valyrian steel
so creating new Valyrian weapons and items were
relatively common for them even though then it
was priced still relatively expensive so so you
have thousands of Valyrian weapons and items in
the ancient Freehold before the Doom but a lot of
them probably lost or destroyed during the actual
Doom but because there were so many of them
just a few survived and eventually leaked or
were sold or stolen and given to other houses in
Westeros and essos currently during the events of
House of the Dragon there are at least 22 Valyrian
steel weapons armor or items if you also include
the very small Valyrian steel links that the
maesters reforge into links when they Master
the higher Arts of the occultan magic like within
the Citadel one of the areas of study a maester
can choose to learn is Magic in the occult itself
when the maesters master a particular art they
add that link on the chain around their neck so
the Valyrian steel link represents magic in the
occult and during the events of Game of Thrones
it's only worn by two maesters like that's how
rare it is Lewin the Starks maester and maester
Morrowind who the show just kind of cut out but
it's just the example that across the many years
the maesters themselves also possessed a very
tiny amount of Valyrian steel that they used
in the making of special links in of those 22
pre-existing Valyrian steel items ice for example
is reforged into two smaller Berlin steel swords
so technically there's like 24 of them that we
know about starting with the most famous one and
working our way down the list there's the cast
pause valyrian dagger now confirmed to have been
reforged by aegon the Conqueror when he added
the secret valyrian message to the actual blade
blackfyre aegon's original Greatsword which was
passed down to each new Targaryen King currently
in the possession of viserys Targaryen here
eventually it was lost during the blackfyre
rebellions later in the timeline so it's probably
somewhere in essos right now there's dark sister
which I already mentioned currently wielded by
Daemon Targaryen originally it was wielded by
aegon's sister wife vicenya before that we don't
know who it belonged to eventually it's given
to the bloodraven later in the timeline he takes
the black later then becomes the Lord Commander a
couple years after that and eventually abandons
the Night's Watch to go north of the wall and
become the three-eyed Raven and after that we
don't know what happened to it so possibly it
still sits under his tree like there were a lot
of theories about this when the original Game
of Thrones episodes were airing like is that sword
in the background there really dark sister there's
ice the Stark's Greatsword during the events of
house the dragon it belongs to Creek and Stork
we saw him during episode 1 when the Lords of the
realm were swearing the oath of fealty to renira
Targaryen eventually we know time when Lannister
melted down and reforges it into widow's whale
and oath keeper and one of the other reasons why
nobody ever learned how to make new Valyrian steel
like you can't just take dragonglass crush it up
and try to add it to regular steel and make new
Valyrian steel it's not that simple is because
the valyrians would use special spells when they
were smelting new Valyrian steel and nobody in
present day knows what those spells were so those
are the special magical component to creating new
Valyrian steel we just saw the new Valyrian steel
necklace that Daemon gives to rhaenyra it also
kind of looks like the medal of his rings are
also valyrian still so it's also possible a lot
of the other members in the royal family right
now have Valyrian steel jewelry that's been passed
down through their family aegon the conqueror's
crown was made of Valyrian steel it still exists
during House of the dragon and will probably see
it during season 2 at some point so I won't talk
too much about it right now but it is a big item
during the events of House of the Dragon also
during the events of the show The High towers
are a very big deal their ancestral valyrian blade
belonging to their family is called vigilance it's
probably in the possession of Otto hightower's
older brother Hobart Hightower here because he's
the current lord of the house typically within a
family usually the head of the household is given
their ancestral Valyrian blade if they possess
one Jon Snow's valyrian sword longclaw is the
ancestral blade of house Mormont so during the
house of the Dragon earlier in the timeline it
would still belong to their current head of the
house and the pommel would have still been a bear
not a direwolf the old bear jaor Mormont had it
refashioned into a direwolf when he gave it to
Jon Snow we haven't seen any tarlies as far as
I know but Heartsbane is their ancestral blade
later after his death it would have been given
to Samwell unless he abdicated the head of their
household to someone else within the family we
also just met the Lannisters again during episode
3 during this part of the timeline their family
had the ancestral blade bright Roar eventually
it's lost by tywin's younger brother tyrion's
Uncle when he sails to ancient valyria looking
for Glory that's one of the reasons why Tywin
Lannister wants to melt down ice later in the
timeline and give one of them to Joffrey and
one to Jaime because otherwise he would have
given their families ancestral blade bright
Roar to Joffrey when he took the Iron Throne
lady forlorn is an ancestral sword belonging to
house corbree Nightfall is a sword belonging to
house Harlow red rain is the name of the ancestral
blade belonging to house drumm in present day but
they stole it from house reyne there the house
reyne referenced during the Rains of Castamere
song R.I.P lamentation is the ancestral blade
of house Royce it was lost during the storming
of the Dragon pit which is another big event that
we might see in the final season of House of the
Dragon orphan maker is another sword belonging to
house Roxton and then there are a couple valyrian
weapons and items coming from people in essos
there's a sword called Truth belonging to moredo
rogar unless there's a another curve Valyrian
steel sword belonging to sandok the shadow one
of the soldiers in the service of house rogar
endless the reason their family probably got a
couple of Valyrian steel weapons is because they
got tied up in the later events of House of the
Dragons we might see a version of that play out
in the later Seasons there's a Valyrian steel a
rock the type of weapon you see the doth Rocky
using and how celtegar supposedly possesses a
Valyrian steel axe and they're another vassal
House of House Targaryen kind of like house
valyrian that also have the blood of ancient
valyria in their veins during episode 3 when
they were explaining what happened to crab feeder
there were a lot of theories that crab feeder was
secretly one of the bastards or one of the second
sons of house celtagar because their House's sigil
is a crab we'll probably see a version of
the celtzegars later in the show because the
current Lord of their house joins renera's black
Council then later in the timeline euron Greyjoy
eventually finds Dragon binder of Valyrian steel
horn with the same types of Valyrian glyphs on it
that are on the cat's paws dagger when you blow
it the glyphs glow and it allows you to control
dragons but it also kind of melts the brain of
any regular other person that tries to use it
they kind of imply that targaryens people with
Valyrian blood are the only ones who can use the
horn without being hurt and also during the events
of Game of Thrones Aeron Greyjoy euron greyjoy's
brother has a vision of the future where euron
Greyjoy is sitting on the Iron Throne wearing an
armor suit made entirely of Valyrian steel but
there might be other new Valyrian steel weapons
and items that show up during the events of House
of the dragon that we didn't know about previously
because for instance rhaenyra's necklace is like
a brand new item in the Canon that they introduced
for the show because house velaryon is also so
powerful and they come from ancient Valeria it's
also possible that they have some Valyrian steel
weapons as well if we see any pop-up on the show
of course I'll mention those in videos if you
have any other questions about Valyrian steel
just in general or the weapons that are featured
in the show the books or Game of Thrones just
write them Below in the comments my full episode 4
video will post Sunday just like normal I've got a
couple other bonus videos I'm working on this week
and there are a bunch of other really big series
that I'm doing videos for right now so make sure
to enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
any of those I'll name a giveaway winner the next
time I post the house the dragon video everyone
click here for my Full House of the Dragon episode
3 video and click here for my episode 4 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!